[Music]
the attila's gym in new jersey like all
gyms is a place where athletes go
to work out on machines but it's also
a metaphor for man against the machine
the atillus gym one of the few
businesses in new jersey to defy the
state's draconian shutdown orders on
gyms
and fitness centers we brought you many
updates on this story
we last talked to the owners after they
were arrested last month but that was
not enough
to break their determination to continue
because they are after all americans
now their business license has been
revoked in a political vote called for
by the local mayor
they started living in their gym after a
judge ordered the doors locked and as we
promised we wanted to bring you an
update on where they stand tonight
ian smith and frank trumbetti are the
owners of the attila's gym
courageous men both they join us now
gentlemen thanks so much so much
for coming on so i'll just throw this to
both of you
what is the status tonight are you still
welcoming patrons into your business
absolutely we uh we we had our business
license stripped yesterday
uh we knew going in what the vote was
going to be and it was exactly what what
we were told it was going to be from our
sources we were told
to be five to one i was present at the
meeting while frank kind of held the
fourth down
and um it was very clear as soon as we
walked in that they were there to
accomplish a mission and that mission
was to revoke our business license and
enforce the will of governor murphy
and uh once they did you know we just
got back to business as usual
as as you've noted many times in this
show not a single
transmission of the coronavirus has
occurred in your establishments there's
no medical reason to do this but you've
defied the will of an authoritarian
governor and he's determined to crush
you so how do you think this will end
um we believe it's going to end this we
have the science and data on our side
and we're mandated that he actually
proved to us this and show
us his science and data we i would like
to see his science and data
that shows that our gym and movie
theaters and indoor dining
are dangerous and on top of that i want
to see this science that shows that
a new jersey transit bus can have 60
people in 340 square feet
and that you can actually have full
contact sports outside and everything
else that he has actually
decided to pick and choose who could
open up show me the science
and the data that proves those points
and i'll close my doors if not
i'm here to fight until the end so i
mean you guys started this
as a gym as a business and now you're
embroiled in this
nationwide controversy would it just be
easier to move to florida and buy a
gold's franchise and just kind of
forget all of this why why are you
continuing
you know it it would it would certainly
be easier um
but from from the onset this was this
was about much more than just
uh keeping our business open you know we
we smelled that this was political very
early on
uh and and and our hunch was right um
and we
we don't want to see the country that we
love and the way of life that we love
be ruined with uh with a political
agenda so
we knew what we were we were stepping up
to i don't think that we thought it was
going to get this far
but we're not going to tuck our tail and
run on this one
we're going to see this all the way
through because it is that important
and uh it's about our constitutional
rights no matter what and everybody's
constitutional rights
that's right you smelled that it was
political early on i think that's the
key a lot of people including even this
show
kind of moved forward with total
credulity that the people in charge
would try to do the right thing for the
country you were smart to know that
they're not
at all and so godspeed as always
thank you thank you keep us updated
thank you guys